when the pandemic hit our lives turned
upside down and
everything changed but how many of those
changes will stay with us
we're exploring what to expect next year
and everything from education to travel
and we start with the pandemic itself dr
celine gander is a member of
president-elect biden's covet 19
advisory board she's an epidemiologist
and infectious disease expert at the nyu
grossman school of medicine and bellevue
hospital
in new york city dr gainer good morning
good morning so let me read for our
audience something president-elect biden
said yesterday he said quote
at least a million vaccines sorry our
darkest days in the battle against covet
19
are ahead of us not behind us so what
are the biggest challenges we face
in the year ahead
well i think just in the coming month we
are very concerned about the fact that
hospitals icu's
are currently full doctors and nurses
are burned out they've been
fighting this for months now we are
experiencing
the results of the thanksgiving surge
and now people are traveling for
christmas and new year's and so i think
we're all
really panicking about what it is that
we're going to do on the front lines and
hospitals to take care of all these
patients
you have some staff that are just saying
look i'm fed up i'm quitting
i you know can't do this anymore and
there's not really you can't defense
production
act your way out of a shortage of
healthcare providers you can play maybe
a little
bit around the margins with bringing
people back in from retirement or
promoting medical students to first-year
intern status but that's not
nearly enough to meet the surging needs
right now so if there's
any time i would say to people please do
not travel
this is the time and this emergence of a
new variant makes that even
more urgent well the president-elect as
you know dr gainer says at least a
million vaccines a day
he wants to see in the first hundred
days of his term is that possible
well we're certainly going to have to
ramp up vaccination
and do many more vaccinations per day
in the first week or so we did not get
to a million
vaccinations um we need to be doing a
million vaccinations
per day to be getting to the targets
that the president-elect has
outlined so that's really going to mean
a massive increase
and again you know when you have all of
your doctors and nurses in the hospitals
taking care of sick patients who's going
to give those vaccinations
so we really have a massive manpower
problem right now
dr gander we spoke earlier this morning
with dr tom frieden who said it's so
important for people to continue wearing
those masks
and he sees that happening for the next
several months but do you
see a future in the next six months to a
year where we won't be wearing a mask or
is this sort of the new normal
for for some time
i think unfortunately this is the new
normal for some time i think
six months would be very optimistic
i don't think we're going to have
everybody vaccinated by then and i think
it's really important for people to
understand that
even once you have been vaccinated we do
not know that you can't still
get infected and transmit to other
people all we know is that it will
the vaccine will prevent you from
getting severely ill and from dying
and so even once you are vaccinated it
is really
crucial that you continue to wear a mask
in order to help contain this and you
know i can tell you i'm going to be
vaccinated later this morning myself
i will continue to wear a mask so dr
gander for the american people who
want to know the priorities of the
president-elect's administration when it
comes
to battling the coronavirus laid down
for us what do you expect to see
over the next year well i think you're
going to see a massive increase in
testing it is
really hard to contain something when
you don't know what you're even dealing
with
so it's like a big iceberg we see the
very tip of the iceberg which is the
people who are getting severely ill
ending up in hospitals and dying
but we don't see that massive part of
the iceberg that is underwater which is
all of the people getting infected
and transmitting onward so the only way
to reveal
that invisible part of the iceberg is by
doing massively more testing
the other thing that this uh variant uh
the emergence of this variant has
highlighted is the fact that we are not
doing enough what we call
genomic surveillance so that's not the
regular testing that you do when
somebody
thinks they may have coronavirus that is
much more
intense testing to look at the genome
the genetics of that virus to see if
it's mutating
um and we do not routinely do that the
united kingdom
has already sequenced almost 4 000
separate strains
of the coronavirus we have done barely
40.
so we're not doing nearly enough of this
kind of
surveillance testing as we need to be
doing all right dr gander as always we
thank you very much appreciate it